Monsieur le Commissaire madame la
ministre des engagements forts pour
construire une Europe plus juste ont été
pris à Porto il place l'Union européenne
sur la voie du plein emploi et du
progrès social une action forte et
d'autant plus nécessaire aujourd'hui
dans un contexte d'augmentation du coût
de la vie de pénurie des compétences et
de précanité énergétique pas à pas nous
construisons l'Europe sociale avec les
directives sur les salaires minimaux et
la transparence des rémunérations ou
encore le règlement sur le fond social
climat nous avons avancé à grands pas
ces dernières années cependant le compte
n'y est toujours pas il y a tant de
chantier à finaliser et d'autres à
ouvrir la protection des travailleurs
des plateformes la portabilité des
droits sociaux la garantie des stages de
qualité face aux mutations des marchés
de l'emploi nous devons encadrer le
télétravail assurer un droit réel à la
déconnexion améliorer le bien-être au
travail avec l'Année européenne des
compétences nous devons offrir à chacun
des perspectives le socle européen des
droits sociaux doit rester notre
boussole réaffirmons le ensemble à Porto
et accélérons sa mise en œuvre